Her low freak bitches,
you know,
it's just wild.
I mean,
in Vietnam it's like,
everyone's like,
Vietnam is so beautiful,
you're going to love it.
And I was like,
yeah,
it's definitely beautiful.
But I see poverty and air that God,
no one can breathe.
Everyone's wearing masks
because they can't inhale.
There's no emissions regulations.
Everyone's on like,
I was like,
oh right white trust fund
kids are like Vietnam sputum.
And they say that,
cause they can come back to,
you know,
Williamsburg,
Brooklyn or whatever.
That's the thing.
People love talking about
Brown people being amazing.
It's like,
look,
I don't like,
you're not a better person because
you think Vietnam is amazing.
Like just admit that it's,
we need to,
I mean,
I know we fucked it up a lot of,
it's our fault of what we did in the 70s,
but it was like,
it was,
um,
gave me a lot of anxiety.
You know,
cause it was like,
I mean it was just like the hospitals.
I mean,
we were in a hospital and you know,
we needed four of this machine
that puts babies to sleep.
Pediatric anesthesia is very
different than regular anesthesia.
And it's essentially bringing people
to the brink of death and then bringing
them back.
It's like incredibly fascinating,
uh,
job.
And they had one of the machines that
they need it and knew the pediatric
anesthesiologists.
It's like,
we need four.
And they're like,
we don't have,
we just don't have them in this country.
We just can't do surgery on babies.
It's just not in our purview.
It's not,
oh no,
are,
you know,
so,
so back to,
to the,
you know,
the kids come in with cleft
palates and cleft lips,
which the baby is essentially,
they have trouble breastfeeding.
It's um,
and cleft palates just,
you know,
just kind of this opening here
and a separation malnutrition.
Uh,
Yup.
Exposure to genetics,
uh,
exposure to pollution.
I'm sure all that napalm we dropped
in the 70s didn't really help.
Uh,
but yeah,
and in America it still happens,
but it's handled right away.
It's handled,
it comes out three months later.
It's fixed.
No big deal over there.
Sometimes it's never fixed.
I mean,
you see adults,
you see men that are
50 come in with giant,
giant cleft lips and palates and they've,
and it's even worse in
third world countries,
especially African countries because
there's such a stigma attached to it.
Not only is it,
you know,
in our brains to go like he's different
than me and ostracized or stigmatized
someone,
but,
um,
a lot of more religious countries
think you're the devil or your,
you know,
you can't get a job.
You're completely sequester and
you're thrown out of your family.
And you know,
and I think,
and this is gonna sound Super Corny,
um,
but I guess for me,
I,
I connected so much to
maybe it's cause you know,
we're comedians.
I was like,
look,
if you,
it's one thing to Grub in
with their world country,
it's another thing to
deal with poverty and,
but if you can't smile,
like the basic,
the only real medicine we have,
you know,
everybody has,
and universal medicine of like laughing
and it's how we connect to people.
It's,
I mean,
that's fucked.
Like that was frustrating and a,
it's so easy to fix.
That's the other thing that's like
frustrating is it takes like 30 minutes.
Look at Joaquin Phoenix.
You don't want to live
having anxiety issues.
Like why do I have that?
Why?
What am I afraid of?
You know?
And it's like,
well,
I'm not,
I'm not afraid enough to
where I'm not going to do it,
so let's just not make it a big,
not make it something I don't like.
Obviously I do like it.
That's why I'm doing track.
Obviously I like him and
maybe that's some of doing it.
I don't want to make it something I hate.
I don't want to make it something.
I don't enjoy it because
it's not rational.
That's not why I do this.
I do this because I love it,
so let's not make it something I,
I hate ever.
I try not to.
That's a very rational approach though.
It's very unusual for people.
Yeah.
Like there's nothing in this life.
Like if I want to do it,
that fears going to stop me.
Fears are realistic thing.
It happens.
Yeah.
It's scary to get into the cage.
It's scary to think
about losing w you know,
and I've tasted the most bitter losses
you could ever dream of and it's
devastating.
It's crushing.
That's the most scary thing.
It's not getting beat up.
It's not breaking your nose or breaking
my orbital bone or letting my arm gets
snapped in half.
That's not the scary part
about fighting and what I do.
The scary part is not
being adequate enough,
not being good enough that
you're 100% wasn't good enough.
That's scary.
That's really scary.
And um,
I've had that,
I've had to face that point blank
right in the face many times before.
And it's the hardest thing to do.
Bar none.
It's the hardest thing to
look at yourself and be like,
I didn't,
I wasn't enough.
No one else can be responsible for that.
I fucked up.
I didn't do it.
I have to own this.
And to come back from something like
that and think that you can still,
you can still get it back or you can
still do it again or you could still get
better.
You can learn from that.
That's,
that's also the challenging part of it,
you know,
and that's something that I've,
I've had to,
to get to this point,
I've had to get over those situations
where I thought that my world had ended.
You know,
my second loss to Rhonda
was the most devastating.
The first loss was devastating.
The second loss was ah,
like it was horrible.
I thought my world was,
was coming to an end and you know,
nobody cared about my family and friends,
but the rest of world,
they don't care.
I don't give a shit.
They don't care about second place.
They don't care,
you know.
And um,
they're mean.
People are harsh.
They're mean on social media you have to
get thick skin quick and nobody teaches
you how to deal with that either.
There's no MMA,
social media one on one or like you don't,
you just sink or swim.
You figure it out or you don't
either bothers you or it doesn't,
you know,
either you yell back at
everyone or you don't.
Speaking of getting there,
I tried to watch soccer last night.
He,
and I was going to bring that up.
People tweeted me that you're watching
soccer to a game on Sunday at the
mother's Day.
Mother's Day.
Oh,
shit happened.
All right.
I can't do it.
Oh yeah.
What happened?
Why?
Well,
it was at the store and uh,
we were hanging out in
the secret comedians bar
and soccer was on,
so we just started watching it.
Just started watching that show.
Who had that on?
Ryan White was watching it.
I was watching it.
Some of the employees were watching it,
you know,
um,
who else was in there with us?
Tony was watching at one point,
but I started getting upset if these
dudes getting slapped and going down like
that get hit with a meteor.
I didn't like that.
I'm like,
I just can't support
this kind of nonsense.
You were watching a really good game.
Yeah.
You're really watching a really good game.
It was amazing.
Like skill wise by Munich and the red,
they're the best German team and
this is a champion's league game,
so I didn't know how to explain it.
Champions League is square,
the four best teams in each
league in each country.
Like playing a tournament to,
to be the best club team in Europe.
So Byron is,
is like the number one team in Germany.
Athletical they like number two,
number three right now.
That actually in number,
the number two spot right now.
But last year they finished maybe
second or third at the end there,
they have less money but their coaches
are ex Argentina player and he figured
out a system where they just hustle,
they just out hustle you,
you get the ball and there's three
motherfuckers on you and you're going to
cough it up and they're going to get it.
And they will score a one or two
goals a game and that's enough.
But you know and buying is just so really
skilled that they might be able to,
they beat most teams but athletics
is just so disciplined that you know,
they knocked them out and,
and they're,
they're going to the Champions
League final versus Real Madrid.
So there's two Spanish teams
in the champion's league
final and both of them are
from the same city.
So it's like the Lakers versus
the clippers for like the best.
The championship of what?
W W what?
What are we in?
Like the up North America.
We're going to do a some soccer games.
Man.
You're going to owe you
the world of soccer.
Oh yeah.
He's going to introduce it to me.
Let me know.
It's very exciting.
It's fun.
It's funny though.
I know what you're going to do.
What am I going to come?
And then you're going to talk shit.
You're going to transcode.
Well,
I'll tell you why you people,
I'm telling you right now,
you go start falling down
when people slap you.
Nope.
Nobody likes that.
Nobody.
Nobody likes.
They shouldn't do it.
You shouldn't do it.
It's an MBA now too.
He's in the NBA now.
I don't want to hear this shitty like I,
I've never liked it.
But people do it to get the free kick or
the penalty or to get the other person
sent off.
It's become a part of the game.
It's unfortunate.
So let's just get that out the way
before you come because that's,
you're going to see that.
But besides that,
it's,
it's a,
it's a man's game.
Yeah.
I mean,
get the fuck out of here.
When Raquel Pennington choked out,
Ashley,
Evan Smith Blood was pouring down her
face and she strangled or unconscious with
one second to go with a bulldog
choke in the first round.
That's a girl,
135 pound girl,
and you get smacked of
running down the field.
Like,
oh,
this is bullshit.
Fall.
They hold their mouth.
They roll around like a baby.
Yeah.
And women.
And when you watch women's soccer,
women don't do that.
Women don't do that.
Women do not take dies and get smashed.
Someone needs to start a campaign.
Maybe we can help him.
Okay.